the ukrainian city of la viv is now a de
facto safe haven for citizens as well as
canadian and u.s diplomats who've been
relocated there la viv is about an
hour's drive from poland on the west
side of ukraine and opposite the
disputed donetsk and luhansk regions la
viv is where we find our crystal command
sing tonight crystal what is the mood
like there on the ground right now
calling on the drive into levive the
majority of highway billboards either
featured an ad for the ukrainian
military or had three numbers scrawled
across them four five zero that's
military code for it's okay or all is
calm and that's the message ukrainian
leaders have been trying to spread as
tension with russia ramps up the kremlin
says it's not interested in starting a
war in ukraine but people here are
skeptical of russia's word
still fear has not seized this city in
the west near the polish border very
safe city levi's mayor tells global news
a lot of effort has gone into planning
water can be provided without
electricity should the utility be
targeted medicines have been stockpiled
along with blood supplies
the mayor draws on the city's legendary
lions the story goes they used to roam
the nearby woods and to this day
act as protectors
all
citizens in ukraine
must
be lions strong climates together we
must
send
a russian birth
to
them
protection in ukraine is key as is faith
in such challenging times
chaplain mahalo dukkha says his job now
is to listen and be supportive of all
soldiers and families
there are not only christians in our
army but there are muslims and pagans as
well
each of them has faith in their heart
each of them hopes on protection from
their god
at a nearby pub the ukrainian canadian
owner says the more immediate danger is
the hit to the economy every country is
telling people don't go to ukraine
everybody's telling you to evacuate
ukraine so we're going to have we're
under a serious problem this summer
if if the troops are there not invading
and everybody's not coming canadian
american british even dutch embassies
have set up shop in this city it is
large and it's bustling and while there
is an undercurrent of concern it's not
crippling this country or the spirit of
the people
colleen
crystal command singh in ukraine thanks
crystal